>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: YOU THOUGHT JOE BIDEN
SPENT SEVERAL HUNDREDS YEARS IN
THE UNITED STATES SENATE TO MAKE
IT HARDER FOR YOU TO DISCHARGE
CREDIT CARD DEBT.
BEING A SHILL FOR THE CREDIT
CARD COMPANIES.
HE DID A LOT OF OTHER THINGS.
AT ONE POINT HE WAS DEEP BENEATH
THE EARTH DIGGING FOR COAL TO
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON.
HERE HE IS IN 2008 REMEMBERING
THAT EXPERIENCE.
>> SOME PEOPLE WILL HOLD THIS
AGAINST ME BUT I AM A HARD COAL
MINER FROM SCRANTON,
PENNSYLVANIA.
THAT'S WHERE I WAS BORN AND
RAISED.
>> Tucker: CORRECTION, IT WAS
A HARD COAL.
AFTER HE DOES COAL BIDEN BECAME
A CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER AND THEN
WENT TO AFRICA TO FREE NELSON
MANDELA.
WATCH.
>> [MUFFLED AUDIO].
I GOT ARRESTED TRYING TO SEE
YOU.
I CAME BACK FROM SOUTH AFRICA
TRYING TO SEE NELSON MANDELA AND
GETTING ARRESTED FOR TRYING TO
SEE HIM IN PRISON.
>> Tucker: ARRESTED IN SOUTH
AFRICA FOR TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING.
PRISON CHANGES A MAN.
DID NOT EVEN FAZE JOE BIDEN.
YOU REMEMBER THE TIME HE WHIPPED
CORN POP.
>> CORN POP WAS A BAD DUDE.
HE SAID YOU WALK OUT WITH THAT
CHAIN.
YOU WALK TO THE CAR AND YOU SAY
YOU MAY CUT ME BUT I AM GOING TO
WRAP THIS CHAIN AROUND YOUR
HEAD.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHING].
YOU THOUGHT HE WAS USELESS.
THAT MAN HAS SKILLS.
HE'S DONE A LOT OF INTERESTING
STUFF.
HE HASN'T JUST STOOD UP AND
TALK.
GOT MORE HAIR PLUGS.
HE'S DONE STUFF.
WE LEARNED ABOUT MORE STUFF
TODAY AT A MACK TRUCK FACILITY
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
HE IS DOUBLE CLUTCH A QUADBOX.
HE USED TO DRIVE AN 18 WHEELER.
>> I DROVE AN 18-WHEELER, MAN.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHING].
HAS MARK STEIN DRIVEN AN 18
WHEELER?
HE'S WRITTEN A LOT OF GREAT
BOOKS.
HE WILL ASSESS THE REMARKABLE
CAREER OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
CAN YOU DRIVE AN 18 WHEELER?
>> NONE OF US HAVE THE SKILL SET
JOE BIDEN HAS.
I DEPLOWER YOUR SKEPTICISM OF
THIS.
HE THOUGHT THIS WAS ROAD ISLAND.
HE WAS DRIVING AN 18 WHEELER.
IT WAS A 23 WHEELER BUT CORN POP
STOLE 5 OF THE WHEELS.
IT'S TRUE HE WAS NOT A MINER,
BUT HE HAS SNIFFED THE HAIR OF
A MINER.
WE ARE GETTING HUNG UP ON
DETAILS.
HE SAID HE WAS A FIGHTER PILOT
IN THE SPANISH-AMERICAN WAR AND
YOU GO BANANAS.
BUT HE DID ONCE TAKE A BUSINESS
CLASS FLIGHT TO BARCELONA IN
1978.
WE ARE TOO HUNG UP ON DETAILS.
HE HAS A RICH LIFE.
HE'S DRAN  DRIVEN A 23 WHEELER.
IF HE STAYS UP LATE HE WATCHES
WHEEL OF FORTUNE.
THAT'S A WHEELER.
HE HAS A VERY RICH LIFE.
NONE OF HIS FANTASY ARE AN
INSANE AS THE REALITY OF PUTTING
THE DEFENSE SECRETARY IN
A PLEXIGLAS HELMET AS IF YOU ARE
GOING TO PROJECT HIM INTO SPACE.
>> Tucker: IF I GET IT BOILED
DOWN YOUR ANALYSIS, YOU ARE
SAYING WE NEED TO APPRECIATE
WHAT WE ARE CALLING JOE BIDEN'S
LIVED EXPERIENCE?
>> WELL, I MEAN JOE BIDEN IS
BORED BY POLICY.
HE CAN'T FINISH SENTENCES.
EVEN WHEN HE HAS PEOPLE IN HIS
EARPIECE TELLING HIM THE WORDS
TO SAY.
HE TAILS OFF IN THE SENTENCES
AND STARTS TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
REMEMBER WHEN YOU AND CORN POP
WERE IN THE 18 WHEELER AND YOU
HAD TO DYNAMITE THE PASS PAUSE
THE REPUBLICANS WERE TRYING TO
GET THROUGH TO GET THE BALLOTS
THERE.
YOU HAVE TO DYNAMITE THE WHOLE
THING WITH YOUR 18 WHEELER FULL
OF CREDIT CARDS FROM THE FIRST
NATIONAL BANK OF WUHAN?
AND SUDDENLY JOE BIDEN SPRINGS
TO LIFE.
THAT'S THE REAL JOE BIDEN.
THE ONE IN FRONT OF THE PROMPTER
IS THE ONE WE SHOULD GET RID OF.
>> Tucker: OUR CAMERA MAN IS
LAUGHING.
MARK, THANK YOU AS ALWAYS FOR
MAKI